widely released in 2009 paranormal
activity reignited interest in a
supernatural horror genre
and launched a popular film franchise
while the plot and final act of this
found footage classic seems simple
it actually delves into some pretty
complex issues he has everything you
need to know about the ending of
paranormal activity
after moving into their new san diego
home mika starts to record his
girlfriend katie
as she comes to terms with a troubling
bit of personal history
katie believes that a supernatural
entity has been following her since
childhood
seeing as she and miku have recently
moved in together it only makes sense
that katie reveals her concerns to him
as a result mika invests in a new camera
setup to test katy's theory about being
haunted and to catch
any evidence of a supernatural presence
mika even surprises katie by saying that
the camera will be on 24 7
even when the couple is asleep from here
on else it's clear that mika is obsessed
and he brings the camera everywhere with
him in the house when the couple is
relaxing on the couch
the camera is rolling if they're
swimming it's being recorded
making beaded jewelry with friends you
guessed it mika is filming
he also reviews hours of footage every
day for better or worse the camera and
mika become
inseparable when mika outwardly mocks
the validity of katie's fears she turns
to dr fredericks
a psychic who she hopes can help her
navigate through her experiences
and offer some clarity to her disturbing
history as mika's camera rolls dr
fredericks quickly deduces that the
entity following katie
isn't a ghost at all but a demon unlike
a ghost demons are malicious
dangerous entities that feed off their
victim's negative energy
the psychic explains that the demon will
continue to follow katie wherever she
goes
so this is a problem she can't simply
run away from since demons are beyond dr
frederick's expertise he refers katie to
a demonologist
but before leaving he advises a couple
against tempting the demon into
communicating
or drawing it out in any way a psychic
even directly warns mika to take this
seriously
do you understand me yeah
following the appointment katie wants to
contact the demonologist but mika
immediately shuts the idea down
despite his skepticism about a demonic
entity and dismissive attitude about the
psychic
mika continues to film non-stop after a
few strange but minor occurrences take
place
mika is pleased with himself when he
catches something out of the ordinary on
film
the first credible sign of paranormal
activity is simply a door slightly
moving on its own however the intensity
of these events steadily grows with each
passing night
for example during night 5 of recording
the couple hears a mysterious third from
another room in the house
the next day mika checks an audio
recording of the event and discovers a
strange sound which he and katie are
unable to recognize as an animal or any
type of electrical interference
still it gives mika another opportunity
to clown around
what is your quest what is your favorite
color
another odd occurrence happens on night
15 when the camera catches footage of
katie getting out of bed in the middle
of the night in a trance-like state
for two hours straight she stands still
beside the bed before walking to the
backyard in a daze when mika shows her
the footage
kt doesn't seem to have any recollection
of doing this the night before
though mika starts out as a rather
confident non-believer
he quickly becomes consumed with
capturing every paranormal event on film
taking things to a more dangerous level
mika goes against the sidekick's
warnings and katie's wishes
and tries to communicate directly with
the demon mika decides to borrow a ouija
board which makes katie absolutely livid
they leave the board alone and go out
for the night but its presence is enough
to invoke a response from the demon
after a few moments of silence the
planchette begins to move on its own
then the board spontaneously catches on
fire leaving behind a series of strange
marks on its surface
when miko discovers the marked board and
looks over the footage he's convinced
that a demon is attempting to tell them
something
he then begins trying to solve a puzzle
that likely doesn't even exist
katie however has her own thoughts about
mika's ouija board experiment
that thing says on the ouija board what
katie really wants as mika to stop
playing games and call a demonologist
but he continues to assert that he has a
situation
under control on night 17 mika pours
talcum powder all over the upstairs
floor to capture more evidence of the
demon on film
katie is confused about what the
experiment will prove since the two know
the demon does
in fact exist however she gives in and
makes him agree that if things escalate
after his talcum powder trick
she's calling the demonologist to step
in on the night of the talcum powder
stunt katy and mika are woken up by loud
creeks in the house
more alarming they find that a trail of
footprints has been left behind in the
powder and they lead up to the attic
katy believes this is a trap meant to
lure the couple into the attic
and harm them but mika was unfazed after
fearlessly venturing into the attic he
returns with a burnt picture of katie as
a child this discovery shocks katie as
he images from her childhood home that
had burned down and
it's impossible that it could have found
its way into the attic after all these
years
katie has finally had enough and tries
to contact the demonologist
unfortunately he's out of the country
so she asks dr fred riggs to come back
to their home as soon as a sidekick
steps through the front door
he immediately comments that the demonic
energy in the home is overwhelming
and in a rare move for a horror film he
acts like any normal person would
this is overpowering it's getting worse
yes it certainly doesn't like that i'm
here and i cannot help you
what in fact i've got to get out of here
after failing to secure help from both
the demonologists and dr fredericks
katie and mika are seemingly out of
options in typical
mega fashion he decides to take matters
into his own hands yet again
but this time he actually uncovers some
useful information
apparently their demon roommate has a
track record of terrorizing young women
the previous victim a woman named diane
was also haunted by a supernatural
entity when she was eight
after calling an exorcist her state
worsened dramatically
and the demon presumably killed diane
and jumps to katie
with this knowledge at their disposal
katie has to now confront the notion
that a professional may actually worsen
her situation
rather than help it on night 20 of
recording the haunting becomes far more
aggressive than ever before
at 4 32 am katie is dragged from her bed
screaming for help the following day she
reveals a bite mark left by the demon
on her back realizing that things have
escalated to dangerous new heights
the two believe they should finally try
to leave the house
after the attack katie begins to act
very strangely
mikia is clearly overwhelmed and finds
her in a catatonic state
clutching a cross in her hands katie is
unresponsive and she's grasped across so
hard that her hand is bleeding
mika seemingly at his wit's end burns
across from the fireplace
after mika destroys the cross and is
ready to escape the house
katie has had a complete change of heart
and insists he'll be safe there
mika gives in to her request unaware
that the katie he knew is gone for good
the next night the camera footage shows
her slipping out of bed
or me curiously asleep for two hours she
silently watches him before slowly
leaving the room moments later he gets
an extreme wake-up call
[Applause]
after mika disappears into the darkness
it's clear that he had fallen victim to
the demon's trap suddenly mika's
lifeless body is thrown at the camera he
loves so much
the obviously possessed katie is
standing in the doorway as she crawls
over mika's body
her face changes into a demonic
expression and she lunges at the camera
throughout paranormal activity miku is
shown in a less than favorable light
before experiencing the paranormal
himself he outright mocks katie and
minimizes her experiences he is
unapologetically dismissive of anything
that will bring her any sort of comfort
he's consistently quick to belittle and
demean her feelings however the moment
mika realizes that what katie is saying
is real
and the demon will make for a compelling
video he's ready to exploit her trauma
for his own selfish ends
while katie is the one at the center of
all these horrifying dramatic events
mika never fails to ignore her wishes
and disregard her thoughts about the
situation
the most egregious of mika's actions is
his willingness to put not only himself
but katie in direct danger by taunting
the demon for the sake of his own ego
your demon's worthless you're worthless
got nothing
the psychic directly spelled out for
mika while communicating with the demon
would be reckless
and katie voiced her opposition to
purposefully drawing the demon out on
multiple occasions
yet mika ignores both of them ultimately
sealing his own fate
mika manages to convince katie and
himself that he is in control of this
situation he knows absolutely nothing
about
he gaslights katie throughout the entire
film and by doing so
he effectively breaks her down allowing
her negative emotions to take hold in
the end
this gave the demon a prime opportunity
to take full control
so while the demon is of course a film's
primary villain
mika's toxicity is the catalyst that led
to katy succumbing to demonic possession
the demon's presence in the home makes
katie amika's existence a living
nightmare
they basically have an uninvited
companion that is constantly watching
their every move
worse is the fact that this entity is
inescapable it will follow katie even if
she moves homes or leaves mika
this means that throughout her life
katie always has something with her at
every moment
though the demon adds a home invasion
aspect to the story paranormal
activities handheld style offers a
voyeuristic view
into the couple's lives and also plays
on their loss of privacy
in every moment of the film miker is
filming his and katie's personal lives
together
even when the couple sleeps the camera
is rolling refusing the two of them any
amount of true solitude
additionally katie both begs and demands
mika to stop filming her but he almost
always refuses
haiti's vulnerable moments such as her
session with the psychic
her fights with mika or her teary
breakdowns are relentlessly recorded
whether she likes it or not her trauma
is being documented and displayed for
all to see
in essence the camera acts as yet
another set of eyes within the house
though mika may have intended for the
camera to capture evidence of the
paranormal
the reality is that it further
eliminates any sense of boundaries that
katie might have still had
one of the most horrifying aspects of
paranormal activity is that the threat
is something entirely inhuman a demon
defies logic
they can move in and out of spaces
regardless of alarm systems
physical barriers or other restraints
because of this the demon is nearly
impossible to overcome with any ordinary
solution
kt readily accepts this reality likely
because her sense of agency has long
been stripped away due to her inability
to fight against the invisible foe
for mika he is unable to grapple with
the lack of control over his new living
situation
and continually tries to claim agency
through nonsensical dangerous stunts
though katie and miku react in different
fashions the end result is the same
a demon holds complete control over
katie and her home it waits for an
opportune time to make a final move
but never loses full governance over the
house the film emanates a feeling of
powerlessness
katie's common sense has rendered
useless by mika's aggressive plays for
dominance and he quickly deprives her of
any authority she may have had
over the situation ultimately the demon
gets exactly what it wants
because it's able to effectively create
a sense of helplessness in both katie
and mika check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]